sometimes people feel he s starting a
company too much until you learn to
conquer that fear
you're gonna stay where you are like
once people understand and taste the
thing they fear it becomes a hell of a
lot less scary
rise and shine it's an expresso time
what's up believe nation it's Ivan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message
don't fear fear too much over to you
Elon Musk also if you want to know what
Elon and other successful entrepreneurs
have to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link de Jong is in
the description below yeah there are
times when something is important enough
you believe it enough that you do it in
spite of fear what motivations that
people need to harness to try to make
change as opposed to just reading about
change and that's not supposed to be an
easy question I think it's it's this
well like I said I think if you if you
study engineering and you figure out how
to design new things then it's
relatively easy to start a company you
just need to get a few like-minded
people with you and and then focus on
creating a prototype the compelling
prototype as soon as possible and then
that you know there's a strong venture
capital industry in this in this country
that will give you funding to take
things to the next level and that that's
all there's to it and you might you know
tried a few times might may or may not
succeed but I think sometimes people
fear fear starting a company too much
you know to say really what's the worst
that could go wrong you're not gonna
starve to death you know you're not
gonna die of exposure what's worse they
can go wrong you know your fears are the
reason why your
small every major bricks that you will
ever make in your life or your business
the big ones the big breakthroughs will
come as a result of you crushing one of
your fears listen you already know what
you need to do you already know what you
need to do to grow your business you
have all the strategies you have a lot
of the tactics you also have a lot of
the excuses as to why you can't do it
you even believe those excuses but
buried under those excuses deep down is
really just a fear you tell yourself
that it's because you don't have enough
money because you don't have enough of
Education of enough connections but
really you're just afraid and until you
learn to conquer that fear
you're gonna stay where you are great
Evan I need to conquer my fears thank
you for the amazing insight listen I
want to help you I want to make sure
you're making progress I'm gonna share
with you three practical ways on how to
actually do it
number one is surround yourself with the
right people you want to surround
yourself with the people who are doing
the thing that you're afraid to do so
that it doesn't actually seem that scary
as an example you want to start a
business that Elon Musk is talking about
in this video you want to start a
business if everybody around you is
talking about how crazy and how scary
and how impossible it is to start a
business then guess what you're gonna
feel really scared to start a business
if your parents need me started in
business and it failed and they think
it's the craziest idea ever
it's gonna be really really hard for you
to go off and do this on your own so if
you're surrounded by negative people who
are afraid constantly of these things
especially the thing that you want to do
then you will have a really hard time
breaking free of that bubble the
solution is be around people who love
doing the thing that you're afraid to do
if you want to start a business
watch Elon Musk videos all the time see
him going forward doing big projects
he's trying to have a back-up plan for
the world and you're worried about
starting a little tiny business right it
just changes the mindset and whether
that's for entrepreneurship or piano or
being a singer or whatever the
aspirations are that you have the more
that you are around the people who are
doing the thing that you are afraid to
do the less you will be afraid to do it
because it becomes a part of your
environment it becomes a part of you
it's part of your body now it's in here
and so
being this crazy scary thing that is out
there and you can do that either in
person you can either find events find
mentors face-to-face people that you can
meet with and talk about it or my
preferred method is aspirational mentors
to have that as part of your daily
routine where you're watching a video
reading a book or listen to the podcast
from the people who are playing at a
high level in that field so that you
stop being afraid
number two is test out small fears
anytime that you are afraid to do
something that's a good indicator that
you should go off and try to do that
thing the only acceptable answer for why
not to do something is this is not an
expression of myself don't confuse it
though don't convince yourself that this
is an expression of yourself try to see
deep down are you saying no because you
actually have a legit reason or just
because you are afraid and the example
users is my nails when I got my nails
done in all orange my dance school won a
competition and I bought a nail spot
retreat for my instructors who
participated and I went with them to
show support and they asked me if I
wanted to get my nails done too and I
said nah that's ridiculous I'm not gonna
get my nails done and I caught myself
why am i saying no and the real deep
reason yes part of it is this isn't an
expression of myself I don't want to
paint my nails that's not how I go
around expressing my creativity but tied
with it was I was afraid I was afraid
because I had to make YouTube videos for
you guys I had big meetings with some
important CEOs I had to speak at a
conference I had a lot of stuff that was
public face and I couldn't just hide in
my room for the next two weeks as I had
my nail polish on and so because that
was one of the reasons why I didn't do
it then I had to do it you need to test
out your small fears something like that
is super easy to do if you can catch it
and so the logic behind the small fears
is if you want to go off and do
something big you want to do this big
scary impossible thing how are you gonna
do that if you can't even paint your
nails you can't even do this little
small thing you want to go to the gym
and lift a thousand pounds but you can't
even lift a five-pound dumbbell so start
look for things that you are afraid of
on a small scale and
when you feel the fear it's not that the
fear goes away
it's feeling the fear and doing it
anyway and in the doing then it becomes
less scary after you've gone through
it's like what was that that's not even
that scary anymore
feel the fear do it anyway you can wait
for when things happen to you and you're
afraid and you try to catch it and you
do it but I prefer for you to find
something even today that you can do
that you are afraid of just to show
yourself and you can do it when you put
your mind to it and tip number three is
have an accountability partner one of
the things that I love doing is when I'm
working on new habit when I'm working on
trying to bust through alluminum belief
it's sometimes hard to catch it it's
sometimes hard to catch when are you
actually afraid of doing something and
when you actually have a legit reason
behind it and we come up with really
great reasons that we convince ourselves
as to why we shouldn't do something and
it can often be helpful to have an
accountability partner somebody in your
life could be a parent could be a friend
could be your your spouse somebody in
your life who can call you out when you
need to be called them when you say
you're not gonna do something because of
this reason they say hmm is that legit
is that true or are you just afraid
right someone who like really gets
excited about being able to call you out
pick that person and have them call you
out and try to process it I'm just a
little bit of you that the reason why
you're saying no is because you're
afraid then you need to go and do it
just to exercise that muscle that when
you find yourself being afraid of
something you are switching your
identity you are building a new identity
for yourself that when you are afraid of
doing something you will find a way to
go and do instead of running the other
way now I've got a really special bonus
clip for you that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for
question of the day I want to know what
is one small fear that you are going to
commit to conquering in some way today
put it down the comments below get
believe nation onside with you let us
hear about your victory and building
that new identity for yourself leave it
below I look forward to hearing what you
have to
day
no I'm a big believer that it's no
different than swimming or riding a bike
two things that didn't come natural to
me I started swimming and riding a bike
late in my life you know like I think I
don't think I started swimming opposed 9
because I feared that yeah
but the answer was literally to just
jump into pools or swimming to just like
skin your knee right to take in a little
water you know I just think you do like
I just like I think the best thing that
could happen to you is if you hear this
advice there's a networking event in
town you go you put on your nice little
Manor Media Henley names heck you walk
up you see somebody you're inspired by
in my five minutes with Gary you go up
and go hi to John and John looks at you
and says get out of my face I actually
think that would be the best thing that
could ever happen to you yeah I think
the best thing that can happen to
somebody when they fear something is for
them to taste the thing they feared
aggressively and immediately when they
could try something yeah I think that it
just eliminates like you'll literally be
there and whether you go crying in the
bathroom
or just like becoming silent or walking
out of there or walking and getting a
you know a you know a cheeseburger for
five seconds and coming back I think the
great thing that would happen to you is
that you'd be like okay well that
happened now what like once people
understand and taste the thing they fear
it becomes a hell of a lot less scary
was there ever a time in your life where
you lost belief in yourself
whoa that many times I've encountered
almost you know death and then I'm
losing it how do you come back from that
tougher experience yes yes how do you
retrain your your body in your mind just
believe in the next record the next
adventure
yeah actually very quick an example for
example is the first time I had to do a
record with the Guinness World Records
swimming under the eyes say 50 meters
one hole here one hole there one meter
of ice and then breath-hold freezing
waters beyond
polar circle situation and then the day
before I had to do the actual record and
went in I had no goggles on I lost away
because I lost a sight got frozen the
cornea the retina and I lost it I did
hundred and thirteen meters you couldn't
find the hole and I couldn't find it all
that gosh I almost no I in the end I
fainted it but I did not feel any agony
and I felt actually quite peaceful after
minutes and minutes are under the eye
swimming you exhaust your body and I got
is this narrowed vision boom just seeing
that that's physiological Wow and then I
went down swimming it was all ok was
like I was swimming into the death
unconsciousness and then somebody
grabbed me a diver and he brought me
back to the 50-meter Oh which are you
kept going past the hole yeah yeah yeah
completely off and then it was the
rehearsal so the diver was are not
underneath the ice he was still up there
but hey I was or four minutes too much
too long then they woke me under the ice
wow that's a moment so how did you come
back from now how do you train your mind
to believe in yourself again at that
moment I actually had 100 i io verk aim
to the fear of death and dying there was
no agony that's strange
and that's past my perception of what I
thought was death
you know hey and there is nobody wants
to die is there maybe it's much more
beautiful out there huh we're in the
afterlife and now we got a live
I am not afraid to die I'm afraid not to
live yeah quotes and things but based on
experience and so I really defied death
and a fearful death over there
not defying like I did it know what
happened and I learned from it to take
away my fear for death so and then the
other day I only had to do 50 meters
which was a Baltic a couple butterfly
kicks and you're there huh that's it
came out happy yeah yeah that was my
number one I liked it wreck it do you
face fear now when you go into some
extreme challenge or in any part of your
life good question any part of their
life because it's all about the life and
actually no my I'm a man on a mission no
fears no no no not afraid of anything no
I'm a man on a mission
I want to take away fear you know
irrational fears traumatic fears fears
created because you do not handle mental
issues
nice grief emotion PTSD trauma
depression those things we are going to
tackle and somebody's got to do this and
I should have no fear to accomplish that
mmm you know a man on a mission should
not think in fear you should go and
accomplish his mission yeah and be
focused so there I am I feel feel like
everybody because it's natural to mmm
you feel fear failures or you said no no
I fear I feel you fear like everybody
but it doesn't hold you back from moving
for not come on man it's a much too
important raise your standard Apple at
the core its core value is that
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me if you guys want
to keep learning from Elon Musk and
understand what his crazy insane work
schedule looks like check out the video
next to me I think you're gonna enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
well what's the difference between
really believing in you ideals and
sticking sticking to them